[Music]
hey man she's not Bitcoin for just like
dye stuff what do you really use that
for not like money hey so what do you
use Bitcoin for you're not just trying
to invest it
I heard you know it's gonna increase in
value well I use it mostly as an
investment but you know I used for like
online tipping and small purchases and
stuff there's a lot of things you could
use it for it to be honest
yeah buy a polar bear you're about a
polar bear I said nah but I tried to get
a mail-order bride once it's not for
real I didn't go through with you cuz it
was kind of fishy hey what do you pick
one for I don't really want to talk
about on camera okay you can tell me
though what do you really buy I choose
office wait this whole enemy to do about
the soccer do we softer screws yeah I
get it you're a gangster don't use ice
up on the dark one now you could be
getting all this cool stuff I do get
cool stuff like what like video games
shoes where people think this is all
spooky weirdness because some
cryptocurrency so it's like a
peer-to-peer system where you have
different servers that are verifying
transactions with each other but like a
private corporation I'm talking about
the Federal Reserve I've never been on
the dark web do you know what comes up
you get on there no that's sticky icky
icky all the diesel nugs moon rocks rich
rovol pills ecstasy moly same thing is
it there's honey hash there's dad
gorilla glue blueberry diesel bug 500
grams of Columbia fish-scale cocaine ask
the amount of bitcoins algorithmically
base depending on the time it's
mushrooms
acid mushrooms a grenade launchers a bow
and arrow just a bow for like a young
girl if you have a daughter you hire a
boat put it in her hair shirt suffice to
say it's all encrypted so usually that's
like an amalgamation of a bunch of TC b
to c b QC b QV c you see shark tank Lori
she's the queen of that click Santa
other cryptocurrency you know that
you're saying my by we suggest one of
our leading that's why I'm here I got a
guy all right let's go yeah stick up
this way
[Music]
[Applause]